lentement et entouré de toutes les
précautions elle sort des réserves
cette dernière oeuvre de rodin va
rejoindre quatre autres sculptures du
maître al étage du musée
un buste d'un certain georges leygues
berruyer bien inspiré georges perec
c'est ce que j'appellerais un homme de
l'ombre il travaille au secrétariat des
beaux-arts pour le ministère de
l'instruction publique et des cultes et
georges fenech est l'ami de rodin à
l'époque où radin n'est pas encore le
grand sculpteur qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
il va favoriser la carrière de rodin il
va l'aider à lui obtenir la légion
d'honneur en 1887 il va lui trouver un
grand atelier pour auguste rodin puisse
travailler à l'aise et surtout il va
acheter des oeuvres de rawdon cinq
pièces légué par la famille avec à la
ville en 1946 et qui font désormais
partie des joyaux des collections du
musée de berry et parmi ses oeuvres un
trio et à observer
plus particulièrement on a trois
sculptures qui ont été faits pour le
projet magistral d'auguste rodin qui l'a
qu'il occupait toute sa vie pratiquement
2899 117 et ce projet c'est la porte de
l'enfer qui devait fermer le musée des
arts décoratifs au palais d'orsay un
projet qui n'a jamais abouti
aujourd'hui il nous reste ses études que
l'on apprécie désormais comme des
oeuvres à part entière expressivité
dynamisme et réalisme des corps cette
sève est un concentré du style rodin là
on a une culture qui est assez dynamique
des postures particulière
titude particulière des gestes qu'on va
pas retrouver dans les sauts votre rêve
qu'on trouve dans l'histoire de l'art
ces oeuvres inspire encore des artistes
d'aujourd'hui
elles sont à voir ou à dessiner jusqu'en
décembre prochain